your insurance agency the sponsors of
this next segment has partnered with
aetna to help make sure that you do not
miss your annual enrollment period
window it's closing very soon on
december 7th so here's what you need to
know
[Music]
hello my name is chris carruthers with
your insurance agency today we're here
to talk to you about medicare open
enrollment ending december 7th today we
are in summerlin here at the
headquarters of aetna healthcare and
today our guest is jody phelps with
aetna the broker manager
jody what is the most frequently asked
question that people are asking about
medicare today hi chris welcome to aetna
members on any plan are often asking
what happens if i don't do anything
during aep well their plan benefits
won't stop it'll keep going but they may
be missing out on some valuable benefits
that could help them schedule time with
your local broker to review your plan
benefits and co-pays to see if you'll be
saving any additional money out of
pocket savings of any size could help as
anyone especially if they're on a fixed
income chris what are some frequently
asked questions that you're getting from
your clients wow well one question that
people are asking about is what's next
so what's next is waiting for their id
cards to come in the mail and they're
playing booklets if you don't receive
them contact your broker so they can
help make sure you do receive them
the other thing we're dealing with right
now is a lot of changes coming with
health care and what's been happening
when people are calling 800 numbers and
so because of that they may be waking up
in january on the wrong plan because
they called outside of the state
so the bottom line is we have an open
enrollment period from january through
march where you can make a plan change
so call a local broker to get local
support from a person that's here to
serve you and if you don't have a local
broker you can stop by one of these
enrollment stations to come by and get
some help yeah you can find your
insurance agency at a local albertsons
throughout the valley from now until
december 7th you can find them at
decatur and blue diamond charleston and
rainbow boulder highway and tropicana
and you can also find us at the malls we
have the galleria mall in henderson as
well as the meadows mall at valley view
and the 95 freeway
we work extended hours so during mall
hours we're open for you you can also
call us by telephone or virtual visits
as well
thank you your insurance agency for
sponsoring that segment contact a local
broker before december 7th everybody you
can find them at the meadows or galleria
mall for more information just visit y i
y-i-a-l-v dot com slash locations we'll
be